gregor gysi den ich jetzt herzlich
begrüße sie waren ja eigentlich auch
schon mal alles senator
parteivorsitzender fraktionschef aber
bundesminister das fehlt ihnen noch
meinen sie dass wir irgendwann erreichen
können das glaube ich nicht obwohl man
natürlich einsehen muss konrad adenauer
war 73 als der bundeskanzler wurde ich
bin gerade 73
also wir haben dieses neue kabinett
jetzt gesehen vereinigt mehrere olaf
scholz wenn sie sich das ganze
gesamtpaket angucken auch mit dem
koalitionsvertrag wie bewerten sie die
neue regierung na ja man soll ja am
anfang nicht gleich irgendwelche
vorurteile pflegen sage ich mal deshalb
will ich außerdem bin ich ein
zweckoptimist billig hoffen dass hier
wirklich ein aufbruch wagen es wird
nicht leicht bei den drei
koalitionspartnern sorgen mache ich mir
ehrlich gesagt bei der sozialen struktur
ich weiß nicht ob die fdp zustimmen kann
leiharbeit werkverträge outsourcing
befristete verträge zumindest weitgehend
zu überwinden und ein bisschen sorgen
mache ich mir bei der außenpolitik was
frau bernburg so angedeutet hat weil ich
glaube dass die konfrontation die
sanktionen gegenüber russland und china
ein dort nichts verändern im gegenteil
die verfestigen sich ich bin da ein
anhänger der politik von willy brandt
wandel durch annäherung
also ich habe das ja in der ddr erlebt
wir hatten vorher kein westfernsehen mit
teams doch plötzlich kamen die also ist
es lockerte sich alles und das halte ich
für ganz wichtig aber vielleicht gibt es
sicher eindruck vielleicht wird das ja
doch anders wir werden das aber
außenpolitik ist auch hier thema und in
der tat mit einer lena baerbock das
erste mal eine frau auch eine sehr junge
frau mit vielen vorstellungen sie will
eine feministische außenpolitik wie muss
ich mir das vorstellen was stellen sie
sich dort ja dass sie bei den gesprächen
mehr darauf achten wird ob eine
gleichstellung der frauen stattfindet
sie wird sein frauen mitnehmen sie wird
dann gesprächen mit frauenorganisationen
führen ab da kann man schon einiges
machen aber sie muss auch wissen ich sag
es mal ganz direkt bei licher auch
senator war entweder regiert der apparat
über dich oder du über den apparat das
ist keine leichte entscheidung wer ist
wirklich chefin oder chef
wenn sie klug es macht seine
antrittsrede und sagt den satz das geht
nicht möchte ich eigentlich die schörnig
will von ihnen immer lösungen haben wie
es geht selbst wenn es kompliziert ist
dass es so eine grundsatzfrage die man
einer politik gerade als chef oder als
chefin eines ministeriums stehen und
beantworten muss aber gegenüber den
anderen staatschefs ist es vielleicht
leichter eine frau zu sein denn wenn ich
mir einen mutigen zb angucke oder an
beiden entschied sind alles alte männer
die ja so eine junge frau vielleicht
ganz anders behandeln wahrscheinlich
sind sie etwas freundlicher zu ihr die
waren ja auch freundlicher zu angela
merkel aber deren stärke bestand darin
wenn etwas völlig festgefahren war fiel
er immer noch irgendeinen kompromiss ein
dafür wird sie ja auch so geschätzt
international da bin ich bei vor
baerbock nicht völlig sicher aber
vielleicht überrascht sie uns bei der
angenehm was erwarten sie denn nach den
vorgängen die ja schon zu hören mal von
ihr was sie unternehmen wird zum
beispiel auch im ukraine konflikt der
quandts hier momentan gewaltig was
deutschland denn da unternehmen als
erstes hoffe ich dass putin und beiden
sie sich auf irgendetwas verständigt
haben die haben uns ja beide nicht
erzählt was sie nun da besprochen haben
wir müssen immer beides sehen auf der
einen seite die fehler russlands ganz
klar diese truppenstärken an der grenze
auf der anderen seite die ukraine war
verpflichtet die gebiete für autonomen
zu erklären wahlen durchzuführen ist
nicht passiert danach erst ist ja
russland verpflichtet seine truppen
abzuziehen also das hat auf beiden
seiten beide haben immer ihre begründung
aber eine invasion wäre natürlich
furchtbar also ich hoffe dass man die
verhindern kann aber russland will
natürlich auch nicht von der nato
eingekreist werden und darüber werden
die beiden gesprochen haben ich weiß
natürlich nicht was dabei herausgekommen
ist aber ich hoffe eine lösung und
deutschland soll sie nur vermittlerrolle
anstreben wir können immer die ersten
sein die sanktionen braucht man es so
weiter und wir können versuchen zu
vermitteln ich glaube aufgrund unserer
geschichte ist das sogar historisch
notwendig gerade wir auch im konflikt
mit russland usw müssten vermitteln
obfrau baerbock das will da habe ich
noch meine zweifel aber vielleicht wird
es ja scholz und vielleicht macht er
dann etwas mehr außenpolitik werden es
erleben die bundeskanzlerin hat nie
einen zweifel daran gelassen dass sie
für die ukraine eintritt aber sie hat
auch diese beitrittsperspektive die
manch anderer westlicher staatsführer
den ukrainern gegeben hat in die nato
hat sie nie vertreten das wäre
wahrscheinlich auch der falsche schritt
auch in ihrem sinne glaube ich ag sie
aber wie kann man denn die ukraine
schützen vor der aggressionen in sagen
wir könnten zu irgendeinem zeitpunkt
finde ich sehen wahrscheinlich in meiner
partei nicht alle so
beitrittsverhandlungen zur eu aufnehmen
nicht zu früh test haben wir haben
ungarn und polen und anderen ländern
gesehen aber die verhandlung kann man
aufnehmen und noch nie ist russland in
ein eu-land eingedrungen also in solche
solche beitrittsverhandlungen können
nutzen wenn man die ukraine wirklich in
die nato aufnehmen dann stellen wir die
nato direkt an den grenzen russlands
glaube dass die rote linie überschritten
und deshalb glaube ich dass beiden und
putin sich genau darüber unterhalten
haben wo sozusagen die nervt grenze
liegt ich wissen sie da ich älter bin
habe ich erlebt wie
rohstoff versucht hat atomraketen auf
kuba zu stationieren und kennedy am
telefon gesagt hat dafür ist der breiten
den dritten weltkrieg zu führen er wird
die schiffe nicht durchlassen man kann
ja aussagen gruppe ein souveräner staat
fakten sollten sich
und da hat rohstoff die schiffe wieder
umkehren lassen das heißt es gibt
grenzen die man nicht überschreiten darf
man so wie damals rohstoffs die schiffer
hat umkehren lassen sollten wir nicht zu
weit gehen bei der einkreisung russlands
weil sie das missverstehen nicht als
sicherheit für die staaten sondern als
unsicherheit für den eigenen stall also
wenn wir da vermitteln wenn wir da was
erreichen im jahr nato nicht
dann können wir wahrscheinlich die
ukraine am besten schützen vielen dank
gregor gysi die ministerien werden
nachher noch ihre starts minister und
staatssekretäre benennen vielleicht
fehlt da noch man auch nicht haben
sondern ich auch nicht aggressiver
gregor gysi und damit zurück zuerst
schärfer